[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo nos
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
y encontrar un trabajo es uno de los
objetivos son más importantes de los
migrantes en el país de destino pero
hallar uno que les brinde todas las
garantías y que respete sus derechos es
el desafío según la organización
internacional para las migraciones los
trabajadores migrantes cubren más plazas
de alto riesgo que los nacionales y es
más probable que se emplean en trabajos
informales sin las condiciones ni los
beneficios que les brinden salarios
salud y seguridad en nueva york' por
ejemplo es común ver a los latinos en la
labor de recicladores un trabajo digno y
que contribuye de manera positiva al
medio ambiente pero que es poco valorado
veamos a continuación la historia de
laurentino y sus colegas
laurentino deambula por las calles de
brooklyn en busca de latas de aluminio y
botellas de plástico lo hace seis días a
la semana de seis de la mañana a cinco
de la tarde por cada pieza que logra
recoger son cinco centavos que se lleva
a casa
pues que le puedo decir pues como a
todos luego de trabajar por eso ando
luchando de aquí
pues yo aunque tenga residencia pero no
no tengo apoyo del gobierno
este mexicano de 80 años gana entre 30 y
40 dólares por día pero el dinero no le
alcanza para vivir en una de las
ciudades más costosas del mundo como el
al menos 10.000 recicladores hacen el
mismo trabajo y la mayoría son migrantes
[Aplausos]
los recolectores no sólo contribuyen en
virtud del volumen y no simplemente el
volumen de los materiales que son
capaces de manejar y procesar y por lo
tanto eliminar del flujo de residuos
sino también en términos de calidad de
los materiales que son mucho más
propensos a ser reutilizados
las ganancias aquí dependerán de si
además ayudan a clasificar y empaquetar
latas y botellas eso les garantiza un
dinero extra
soy mi propio empleador
trabajo las horas que yo quiero
un valor que respetaban si el trabajo
el apoyo de los salarios
igual que se emplea el empleado que se
emplea con trabajo duro
una caja regular
los recicladores en nuevayork son una
fuerza de trabajo esencial pero su
aporte al medio ambiente es poco
valorado
porque algo
que no les gusta que recojamos su
reciclo los hechos como animalito en
mayor
y pues no tienes que uno vive y
hay partes que yo no entiendo por qué la
gente
no nos quieren
[Música]
la suma de 5 centavos por lata que se
paga se mantiene desde 1982 y los
recicladores no son trabajadores
oficiales no tienen beneficios y tampoco
el seguro médico que les brindaría una
labor plenamente reconocida
la brecha existente entre trabajadores
nacionales e inmigrantes es amplia y se
hizo mucho más evidente con la pandemia
en 2020 según la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económicos
la pérdida de empleos impacto
particularmente a los extranjeros este y
otros datos en el siguiente informe
con fronteras cerradas y restricciones a
los desplazamientos alrededor del mundo
la pandemia tuvo un gran impacto en las
migraciones internacionales dado que la
mayoría de países restringieron las
libertades de movilidad para frenar la
expansión del coronavirus el informe
anual de la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico la
ocde
afirma que la migración permanente hacia
países ricos cayó más de un 30 por
ciento hasta los 37 millones el nivel
más bajo desde 2003
los flujos migratorios fueron
fuertemente afectados por la pandemia de
hecho si excluimos las transiciones de
migrantes permanentes del país de
destino a otro la caída del 40% traen es
el factor el philips & el número de
nuevas solicitudes de asilo en países de
la ocde disminuyeron un 31 por ciento en
2020 la mayoría de solicitudes de asilo
provienen de ciudadanos originarios de
venezuela afganistán y siria algunos
cambios en la política migratoria de
ciertos estados de la ocde en 2020
simplificaron los procesos para las
personas desplazadas por ejemplo
facilitar la entrada de trabajadores
esenciales en los de la salud de la
agricultura y permitir a los estudiantes
internacionales aplazar sus estudios o
seguirlos online al mismo tiempo la
pandemia también revirtió algunos
avances en materia de integración
dobló sus during cuenta la pérdida de
empleos en de su nivel de afecto
desproporcionadamente las personas
migrantes a pesar de los planes para
mantener trabajos ejecutados en varios
países de la ocde se abrió una brecha un
2% entre las tasas de desempleo de los
nacidos en el extranjero respecto a la
de los locales la ocde también examinó
el impacto de la migración en las
economías nacionales concluyendo que los
inmigrantes pagan más impuestos que los
beneficios que reciben a cambio
utilización
la óyeme estima que hay unos 169
millones de trabajadores migrantes en el
mundo y más de dos terceras partes se
concentran en países de altos ingresos
la mayoría de esos trabajadores son
hombres y al menos 70 millones mujeres
quienes se enfrentan a más obstáculos
socioeconómicos por cuestiones de género
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 sigan con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]